you know as I was standing today and
looking at the thousands of people that
were there um the dozens of Television
cameras from all over the United States
in the world we had the governor we had
the mayor we had you know this elected
official that elected official and I
thought to myself how is our beautiful
martyr our beautiful boy wedia any
different from all of the wias all of
the beautiful Martyrs in Gaza 750 of
them he was stabbed in Hena crime yes
but I ask you do you think a bomb that
falls from the sky does less damage than
a knife that stabs 12 or 26 times do you
think that's a pretty image because it
isn't so what is it about this situation
that woke up the conscience of our
governor and our mayor and our media we
have to understand there is no
difference between this heinous crime
here which we all must condemn and
clearly everybody gets that and the
manyas and this is the father's feeling
this is not just me he said my son is a
representation of what is happening and
to feel for him we have to feel for
everyone